[موسيقى]
سفارات الانذار تدوي مجددا في العاصمه
الاوكرانيه
في قلبي كيف تفحل السلطات دفاعاتها
الارضيه
هجوم الروسي اخر يستهدف العاصمه ومقاطعه
اخرى قبيل ساعه من دخول العام الجديد وفقا
للجيش الاوكراني استهدفت الاراضي
الاوكرانيه ب 20 صاروخ روسيا من نوع كروس
اطلقت من بحر قزوين القوات الاوكرانيه
قالت انها اسقطت سته منها في كيف
لكن القصفه طال ثلاث مناطق مدنيه في
العاصمه وضواحيها تحدثت السلطات عن مقتل
مدني واصابه 13
بينهم صحفي ياباني
الاعياد لكن هذا ما جرى ابناؤنا في
الخنادق ونحن هنا هذا هو قدرنا لكننا
سننتصر
اتباعا منذ ايام هذه هديتهم الينا في
الاعياد لا نتوقع منهم شيئا اخر
احد اكبر فنادق كيف لم ينجه والاخر تحولت
واجهته الى اطلال وحل الخراب في محيطه ليس
الهجوم الاول ولن يكون الاخير على الارجح
هذا القصف الجوي الجديد الذي تتعرض له
كيابه مقاطعه اخرى دفع السلطات الاوكرانيه
للقول بان روسيا غير جاده في الجلوس على
طاوله الحوار
حوار كانت اوكرانيا قد وضعت له شروطا
واكدت عدم التنازل عنها بدءا بالوقف
الفوري للقذف الروسي وانتهاء بانسحاب
القوات الروسيه من كامل الاراضي
الاوكرانيه ومع انقضاء العام ودخول عام
جديد تبدو الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا
اخذه بالتمدد ولا يلوح حتى الان حل سياسيا
في الافق القريب تامر صمادي الجزيره كيف